a lot of people can't fix something if
they don't know it's a problem and Skid
Row is a place that to even understand
and comprehend what's happening I
believe that you have to go there lunch
on me we make the community better one
mill at a time one dance at a time one
party at a time I want to in starvation
by redirecting waste with as much food
as we have around the world starvation
is kind of like a silly concept
unless there's famine there's really no
excuse Skid Row is the biggest
population for homeless in America we
live in a society where fresh foods are
privileged instead of a right and I
believe it's the opposite
so with lunch on me it's about bringing
fresh foods to people in need that can't
afford it and that's our food drive guys
we pretty much pull up to different
tents all throughout Skid Row and hand
out fresh foods you hungry laughs
[Music]
we make large helpings basically
probably twice the size of a normal meal
so we try and give them enough fat least
cover two meals for the day
[Music]
you got it we have people that are just
like oh my gosh I didn't eat in three
days and they rip open the food
immediately and start eating like god
bless you thank you giving someone a hot
meal and they didn't expect enough you
can only love that if every person gave
there would be so many more people that
feel fulfilled because that giving is
the only way I feel like you can fill up
your cup what motivates me is love just
love for mankind love for Humanity it's
special when you feel love then you can
receive love every day and I know a lot
of people that are homeless they're not
able to receive it they're living alone
there on the streets we're focused on
Indian starvation but that's secondary
to the connection that humans need to
have in order for us to have a global
change you know we'll go deliver meal
and end up talking on the street for ten
hours
homeless people are disregarded every
single day they're dehumanized and I
thought it was really important to
restore the understanding of who these
people are which are people it's just a
living condition it's just what you're
seeing by the eye their souls and their
spirits they're the most loving people
they're the most generous people
the drive-bys are quick you know you
give someone food and you're out I felt
it was very important that because we're
gonna be on Skid Row six days a week
that we know who our neighbors are and
we connect with them and so I decided to
throw parties because I was like okay
let's create a sacred space where people
can come together and there's food in
there celebration and there's music the
block party is called love without
reason because I think it's very
important to know that there's no reason
for it other than that we all need to
love
[Applause]
this event just seen before just it's
the reason why we do it
you see all these extreme transitions
all within you know a couple hours they
bring in great barbers you know that
come and build everyone's confidence and
what's really nice is you see people you
know going into a chair and coming out
in their new person
every day it's working towards creating
a better community better bonds with
people and think that's important and
hopefully we could grow and expand just
help people you know feed people make
sure every no one's going without a meal
I think that these acts of kindness if
we take them everywhere it would better
the entire world I gonna get allowed to
[Music]